économie à présent avec Jean-Pierre
Sauvestre bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
adjoint au maire en charge des affaires
économiques à Coignières un soulagement
pour vous la zone d'activité le forum va
enfin tourner la page après le départ de
sa locomotive une grande enseigne de
bricolage c'était en 2009 3 4 ans ce
sont écoulés le site a tenté de survivre
et finalement vous avez réussi à lui
donner une seconde vie pourquoi ça a
pris si longtemps quatre ans
effectivement 4 ans depuis le départ de
Castorama sur le site l'autre zone
d'activités et de commerce des portes de
Chevreuse
castorama est parti en mars 2009
effectivement et depuis il y a eu de
multiples péripéties je dirais
péripéties administrative mais
péripéties également commerciales nous
avons eu tout d'abord un envahissement
du terrain par les gens du voyage dès
mars 2009 même avant le départ de
Castorama
et ensuite nous avons présenté le
spromoteur la SOPIC qui est un promoteur
du Nord de la France a présenté un
dossier en CDAC la commission
départementale de
d'agencement commercial et cette cette
commission a mis un avis très favorable
mais derrière immédiatement un recours
d'un concurrent de Décathlon qui devait
venir s'installer qui doit venir
s'installer avec Truffaut à l'époque
a été tenté immédiatement derrière les
commissions départementales et donc il a
fallu recours à une commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial en septembre
2009 alors c'est juste le jeu de la
concurrence qui fait que ça a été
compliqué c'est pas le jeu de la culture
et qui désirait s'installer également
sur le forum et donc qui a émis un
recours sur la l'autorisation de la
Commission départementale que vous avez
cité Décathlon c'est l'enseigne et qui
viendra s'installer la Décathlon va
venir s'installer prochainement comme
vous l'avez indiqué tout à l'heure et
ensuite
Truffaut devait venir s'installer avec
Décathlon Truffaut trouveront le temps
un peu long c'est retiré du projet et
donc le promoteur se pique a dû revoir
son projet et maintenant nous avons un
projet qui comporte quatre enseignes
Décathlon toujours là Decathlon que nous
attendons et que toute la zone de
chalandise attend parce que c'est un
magasin qui apporte beaucoup de jeux
d'articles de sport
les administrer de tout de tout le
secteur c'est tout de même très
intéressant également fly qui est déjà
sur le secteur mais qui va passer la rue
traverser la rue Darty qui s'installe
également et un magasin de d'équipements
de la maison et de la personne Babou qui
complète les quatre enseignes de
renommée un peu nationale alors quatre
enseigne assez importantes qui
s'installe je vous pose cette question
c'était uniquement le jeu des recours
qui a rendu le dossier un petit peu
difficile à avancer c'était pas le site
qui n'était pas attractif parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de concurrence il y en a
peut-être même pas du tout aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y en avait par le passé à
l'ouverture de cette zone commerciale le
forum
des années 70 c'est à peu près la zone
du forum fin des années 70 début des
années 80 effectivement c'est plus la
même aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
concurrence et même sur Coignières et
même sur Coignières mais c'est ce sont
ces procédures administratives et c'est
recours multiples puisqu'ensuit nous
avons représenté un dossier le promoteur
à représenter un dossier avec ces quatre
enseignes et donc là il y a eu un
nouveau recours arrivera
qui voulait obtenir une prestation en
échange et donc encore quelques mois de
retard et donc là maintenant nous sommes
tout de même tout de même tout de même
réjouis d'accueillir maintenant ces
quatre enseignes qui vont permettre de
d'apporter une nouvelle activité un
nouveau souple à centre commercial les
travaux qui ont débuté on va le voir en
images bien sûr 6 mois de démolition
elle les travaux véritablement de
construction qui débutent à présent
inauguration ce lundi matin 4 enseignes
sur 14000 mètres carrés vont ouvrir
quand c'est les nouvelles enseignes que
vous aviez cité alors la première
enseigne Décathlon qui désire ouvrir dès
que possible et c'est une ouverture qui
est prévue pour la rentrée après les
vacances festivales c'est-à-dire en
septembre-octobre probablement et les
trois autres enseignes
ouvriront dans la foulée c'est-à-dire
d'ici à la fin de l'année 2013 vous avez
un droit de regard sur les différentes
enseignes qui s'installaient justement
pour éviter la concurrence entre les
différents sites de la ville même de
Coignières parce que sur Coignières il y
a plusieurs centres commerciaux il y a
plusieurs centres il y a plusieurs
centres commerciaux bien sûr je reviens
sur le centre
récent des portes de Chevreuse donc on
s'est installé cette enseigne de
bricolage qui était auparavant
effectivement mais
ce sont les ce sont les commerces qui
créent l'attractivité d'une zone et pour
la commune de Coignières le plus il y a
de concurrence effectivement il est
possible pour une personne qui vient sur
Coignières de faire des comparaisons
d'une façon très importante et donc il
reste sur Coignières alors qu'il y a les
mêmes types de magasins sur Coignières
effectivement alors il y aura ces
nouvelles enseignes qui vont s'installer
la grande ancienne de bricolage on a
mentionné tout à l'heure qui était parti
mais il y a quelques autres magasins qui
sont restés pendant toutes ces années
est-ce qu'ils vont aussi connaître un
petit lifting alors depuis 4 ans
effectivement ces magasins souffrent
actuellement il y a sur les 15 autres
magasins du secteur du forum il y a une
dizaine de magasins qui qui sont en
exploitation et il va y avoir un lifting
comme vous dites au mois de juin et
juillet prochain les façades notamment
seront
agréabilité pour permettre d'avoir une
unité maintenant avec les quatre
nouvelles enseignes une unité sur ce
secteur et puis ce qui créera également
avec les portes de Chevreuse pour une
entrée de ville sur Coignières en venant
de Paris notamment une entrée de ville
qui sera de qualité ça va dynamiser
aussi l'emploi sur la commune oui nous
attendons entre 100 et 130 personnes 130
salariés sur les quatre les quatre
enseignes que nous avons cités mais
également un impact indirect sur les
anciens magasins qui vont pouvoir
revivre mon pouvoir j'espère embaucher
ces nouveaux emplois qui vont être créés
seront réservés justement aux habitants
de Coignières nous avons une cellule
emploi à Coignières qui bien sûr est en
contact permanent avec les nouvelles
enseignes qui s'installent et donc nous
proposons bien sûr aux administrés et
aux demandeurs d'emploi de Coignières en
priorité quels sont quels sont leurs
possibilités d'intégrer les nouveaux
nouvelles propositions bien sûr cette
zone doit revivre j'aimerais juste qu'on
regarde sur les autres zones de la ville
de Coignières celle qui se situe par
exemple du côté de la gare pour ceux qui
la fréquenti il visualise sans doute
même ceux qui ne font que y passer en se
dirigeant vers Rambouillet
notamment et sur cette secteur là qu'il
est difficile de dynamiser également
vous avez prévu quelque chose ce secteur
est difficile à dynamiser effectivement
nous avons déjà revu il y a quelques
années déjà la chaussée et puis pour
permettre un meilleur accès à ces
magasins mais il est vrai qu'il nous
faudrait plutôt une sortie sud une
sortie sud qui n'existe pas une
infrastructure routière mais nous
n'avons pas encore de projet sur ce sur
cette sortie pour l'instant cette zone
va rester un petit peu encore on va pas
dire mais en tout cas en difficulté
qui tournent bien non non mais ça n'est
pas ce sont des commerces qui tournent
et qui qui sont en activité et nous
avons également au sein de Coignières
nous avons une agence pour la émotions
et le développement de des affaires
économiques labdec et nous essayons par
ce moyen de fédérer les commerçants de
dynamiser d'animer le commerce sur la
ville une dernière question vous êtes un
responsable politique sur la commune
comme tous les responsables politiques
qui passent sur ce plateau en ce
moment-là la liste d'Henri Payot le
maire sortant au prochain élections
municipales c'est un scout si vous me
dites qu'il y a une liste d'Henri
pailleux
s'il y a une liste là je n'ai pas de
réponse encore à vous donner ce soir en
tout cas on vous aura posé la question
vous reviendrez sur le plateau
il aura cette question puisque les
municipales vous le savez ce sera en
mars et d'ailleurs n'oubliez pas sur
notre antenne en ce moment la municipale
2014 le nouveau numéro du rendez-vous
politique de la rédaction à retrouver
aussi sur notre site Internet et puis en
diffusion le week end merci Jean-Pierre
Sauvestre élu à Coignières en charge les
affaires économiques Coignières qui
relance donc c'est la zone commerciale
baptisée le forum le projet ces enjeux
si vous venez de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil voici un résumé
signé de la rédaction
ça y est le chantier de reconstruction
du forum de Coignières est lancé après 6
mois de démolition les travaux ont été
inaugurés ce lundi avec une tradition
aux fumée de macadam le gigot bitume
j'emballe dans du de la Luft croisée une
dizaine de couches 10 11 12
et après on met des pâtes pétrave toi
la zone laissée à l'abandon après le
départ de Castorama en 2009 n'avait
toujours pas trouvé de repreneur c'est
désormais chose faite Decathlon fly
Babou et Darty devraient se partager les
14000 mètres carrés et ouvrir leurs
portes d'ici le mois de septembre
nouvelle enseigne mais aussi nouveau
bâtiment seul reste la charpente et le
dallage
c'est un changement total puisque les
bâtiments avaient 25 ans un peu plus de
25 ans ici et donc on veut vraiment une
architecture nouvelle le programme va
faire l'objet d'une certification brime
donc certification environnementales et
on va voilà amener encore une fois
beaucoup de beaucoup de fraîcheur et
beaucoup de renouveau ici un bâtiment
remis aux normes environnementales donc
puisque le chantier comprend la
plantation d'arbres ou encore un bassin
de stockage des eaux pluviales mais le
nouveau forum ce sont aussi de nouveaux
emplois pour Coignières et ses alentours
dans le cas de la cellule emploi mise en
place à la mairie et bien on va
participer non pas recrutement mais en
bref on va tout mettre à la disposition
des enseignes pour que le recrutement se
fasse dans des locaux mis à disposition
par la mairie le constructeur lui mis
sur un minimum de 130 emplois pour cet
investissement total de 20 millions
d'euros